hey folks welcome to the dark horse
podcast i have the distinct honor of
sitting today with dr peter mccullough
who is an academic internist a
cardiologist and a trained
epidemiologist in dallas texas dr
mccullough welcome to dark horse thanks
for having me on
so i have been aware of your work now
for i don't know how many months you
have become
a kind of celebrity in heterodox
doctoring circles
in light of your position on
covid and its treatment this is
obviously a very fraught landscape with
a lot of what i regard as political
landmines that are getting in the way of
good doctoring and good science
and i was hoping to talk to you about
what you see from your position in
medicine
well i'm coming up on two years like you
brett of uh really a singular focus on
the medical problem of our lifetimes
and i think a lot of what you just
described is a convergence of of so many
human emotions including personal fear
of infection uh in oneself as well as of
pain and suffering and isolation in
loved ones
and then to see the see the twists and
turns in what medical physicians and
medical staff and ancillary personnel
believe about the pandemic as they
receive information through the media
well
if i might i'm hoping to start somewhere
uh else
i'm watching doctors like you
who are doing what i consider to be the
fundamental job
in medicine which is to scientifically
evaluate phenomena whether that is a
patient who has a mysterious set of
symptoms or whether that's a pandemic
about which we are learning the nature
of the pathogen
doctors are supposed to be
scientists and that means that they
don't simply dispense wisdom from on
high what they do is they use often
informally a version of the scientific
method
to discover the nature of a phenomena a
phenomenon
and
then learn how to effectively treat it
and
doctors like you have been learning
about covet as we all have
but those who have reached a conclusion
that is at odds with the public health
narrative are i'm struggling to find an
alternative term but seem to be
gaslit
you're being told effectively that the
pathogen you're confronting
isn't what you think it is and i'm
wondering what that looks like from your
perspective
well what you describe is what's called
inferential thinking that we're always
drawing inferences from a series of
observations and with a new problem like
this there's a an unfolding new series
of observations that come out basically
almost every day now right or every week
and month that we learn new things so we
actually change our conclusions based on
what we've learned in many ways it's one
of the most exciting times in medical
science and i've witnessed to my entire
career the excitement is extraordinary
and the uh to tensions are great because
there's always tensions as we uh are
humbled
by uh finding out that maybe what we had
previously thought now uh has uh you
know is not supportable that we were on
the wrong track and now we need to
change science is ever changing and
you're right doctors who are treating
patients you have to employ science
based on making inferences but they also
have to employ the art of medicine this
idea of having a medical hunch and
following it to its conclusion the best
we can therapeutically because people
are dying and that's the reason why we
could not wait for large randomized
trials which take two to five years and
then guidelines which take you know many
years after that the institute of
medicine says
from the time something is fully
understood and we have like a prevention
where therapy
applied it takes 17 years for full
implementation we obviously didn't have
that we didn't have 17 days to wait to
treat patients with covet 19. so i've
been involved as you implied very early
on with the early treatment response
that's gained a tremendous amount of
intention including you know basically
historic us senate uh testimony multiple
state senate testimony uh
treatment networks all over the united
states and then uh in in the last year
turned my attention to vaccine safety
and efficacy because like many doctors
uh a
large number of americans
were volunteering for the first of its
kind vaccine program
and
um you know the response is is not
uncommon do you know the very first
doctor
who put a polio patient on the iron lung
machine which actually saved many lives
in the polio pandemic he was thrown off
a staff i mean the history is replete
with this every doctor who had a first
innovation or had a first observation on
something that was a breakthrough
whether it be on the efficacy side or
the safety side
has been basically what you said gaslit
so what i say is and if the gas lighting
is going on it means we're on the right
track
yeah flack over the target
um all right so
there are a number of things i want to
ask you about in the brief time i've got
you
can you tell me
if we step back to let's say
february of 2020
how how dangerous a disease is covid and
then
the same question for the present day to
a doctor like you who has experience and
all the tools necessary at their
disposal
for an infection there probably is no
other infection that we now understand
is so amenable to risk stratification
how can the same viral infection be
fatal
in an octogenarian and have it be less
than a common cold in a kindergarten
aged child that the principle that's
called wrist stratification it's
actually probably due to the density of
ace2 receptors in the human body the
virus actually gains entry into the
human body through the ac2 receptor and
to a lesser extent the tempus 2 receptor
it turns out that we have a lesser
density of h2 receptors in older
individuals those who are smokers and
disease but the virus doesn't the number
of receptors doesn't matter in terms of
entry but the number of receptors uh
that actually exist since they're
destroyed by the entry that the number
the sheer number protect provides
protection
against uh protection against uh
basically a a catastrophe in the lungs
what's called the respiratory distress
syndrome we also know that the
proclivity for blood clotting increases
over time there's thousands of
determinants of coagulation and the very
unique thing about this virus is that
the mode of death is micro blood clots
that occur throughout the body the lungs
and there are fatal thromboembolic
consequences almost every autopsy i'm
aware of fred has shown the lungs are
filled with blood clots at the time of
death so it's the idea that wrist
stratification is so huge and so it can
be very deadly in an octogenarian and is
completely benign in a school-aged
children that risk stratification must
be applied with every single inference
we make in the pandemic
yeah that's fascinating
[Music]
and it is obviously at odds with a
public health response that seems to be
one size fits all almost to a cartoonish
degree the idea that vaccines are
inherently the right response
that
the fact that these vaccines are
incredibly
novel at a technological level they are
marvel but
they are novel and the idea that we
should be interested in
immediately vaccinating the entire world
if we can reach them with these novel
technologies effectively
uh dragging the entire human species
into a
what i would call a uh
an irresponsibly uncontrolled experiment
seems preposterous i mean as you point
out
very young healthy children are
effectively at zero risk from covet is
that a fair statement
it's a fair statement we've looked at
obviously we're at now in the last two
meetings with the fda on the p the
pediatric and adolescent vaccination
september and october of 2021 there's a
general recognition through may that 40
of children have already had covet 19.
that's through may that's before the
delta outbreak the delta outbreak was
huge in the united states you know it
was two-thirds of the peak of our
pre-vaccination peak and we know there
it actually seemed to prey upon the
young and so my estimate would be a i i
would put a number on it eighty percent
of children now that are in the
discussion for vaccination have already
had covet and now the cdc in the last
week has acknowledged uh that they don't
have a single case of someone who has
recovered from covet getting it a second
time and passing to anyone so it's
basically over with we have uh now the
cdc estimates are generally for the
united states 148 million americans
through may are
immune that they actually have had
coveted 19 and they have natural
immunity that's now supported by over
120 studies that's been by the way
accumulated on the brownstone institute
website 120 studies supporting natural
immunity
it's a one and done phenomenon the only
confusion that exists out there is a
second positive test that can happen as
a false positive test and some early
confusion on the original cdc essay not
being able to distinguish between flu
and covet 19 but in terms of scientific
reality one only gets covet 19 infection
once the immunity is robust complete and
durable just like sars kovi one they're
90 similar as the virus that natural
immunity is going to carry us and you're
right the public health response has not
been along the lines of risk
stratification as it is with other
vaccines you know we don't carpet bomb
the entire population for the
meningococcal vaccine it's kids who go
to college and live in dormitories get
the meningococcal vaccine americans
don't have a problem with that because
it's safe and effective and it's
appropriately risk stratified
the same thing with the pneumococcal
vaccine we give the pneumococcal vaccine
to seniors because they're at risk for
pneumococcal pneumonia we don't give it
to children because they're not at risk
the same risk stratification principles
for other vaccines should have always
been applied to the cova 19 vaccines
yes it looks to me and of course i'm a
scientist not a medical doctor but it
looks to me like every normal
medical
standard and
convention has been thrown out that
effectively the standard of care is not
based on the kind of scientific
deliberation that you would imagine
would have to be
at the the foundation
that the right to informed consent is
nowhere in evidence
and that we are effectively
uh
well if this was a scientific question
rather than a medical question
i would say something has started with
the conclusion and worked backwards
which is
the greatest scientific sin that there
is
um and in this case
it has the added horror of putting human
health and well-being in jeopardy
and
i'm not sure the problem is that that
what i've just said
seems to me quite uncontroversial
actually just the simple facts of what
we are doing the idea that anybody would
think to vaccinate children who are safe
from this disease
uh with a vaccine even if we did not
have any evidence of harm which is not
the case
with these vaccines the idea that
anybody would vaccinate people who are
at no risk who have a long life ahead of
them many of whom have already had a
disease that provides robust immunity
the idea that we would expose them to
any risk at all from vaccines that are
so new
is preposterous and yet
when i look at the explanation for why
we're doing that
it's in
vague almost childish terms right the
idea is somehow that vaccines are good
and that you are you know you are doing
something for your child
by uh
by inoculating them
without any
anything that looks like an adult risk
benefit analysis
so
what has happened such that the
interface between the public and
medicine is now looks like
more like pr
and customer service than it does like
science and medicine
one of the most flagrant examples of
what you just mentioned was recently
cnn medical correspondent sanjay gupta
appeared on sesame street
and was with another cnn correspondent
effectively seducing children into
taking the covet 19 vaccine without
presenting a fair balance between the
of potential benefits and risks of the
medical product you know we have laws in
place we have pharmaceutical ever
that americans get a fair balance of
benefits and risks and you're right
that's been abrogated in this case
there's been a giant abrogation of
medical ethics of pharmaceutical uh
pharmacal vigilance and and regulatory
principles uh and it's extraordinarily
dangerous i i think historians will
write about this for years to come how
did how did america go off the rails i
recently had dinner with scott atlas we
spoke at a symposium together and scott
used that term over and over again he
said things are off the rails we're not
following any of the general rules
well what could have been different that
was your question brett what could have
been different what could have been and
should have been different is teams of
doctors
we should have had teams of qualified
doctors working along four principles
and i presented this to america when i
testified in the u.s senate in november
of 2020. i said listen we should have
had a team that was totally focused on
reducing spread of the illness great a
separate team focused on early treatment
yet another team focused on in-hospital
treatment and then a final team focused
on vaccination those teams should have
been gathered they could have met
virtually and they should have given at
least weekly or monthly reports with
evidence reviews and scientific updates
you know we're not having any formal
evidence reviews and scientific updates
in these in the three four important
areas called the four pillars of
pandemic response i ultimately published
that well i can tell you if we had the
right committee structure in place and
and for vaccines we obviously should
have had a data safety monitoring board
a critical event committee in the human
ethics board i think that the mortality
signal emerged on the vaccines january
22nd where we had 182 deaths the eyeball
estimate was 150 deaths total for a
giant vaccine program we know that's the
number for all the vaccines combined in
the united states 278 million shots we
were already had a mortality signal
january 22nd
i think a data safety monitoring board
look at this and i chair day safety
monitoring boards for the nih big pharma
in vitro diagnostics i you know i've
done this dozen or so times actually a
couple dozen times i know what i'm
talking about i've shut down with my
committee's big pharma programs i mean
huge pharma programs our vaccine program
would have been shut down in february
for excess mortality uh in america this
would have been very similar to the
swine flu
vaccine in 1976 it would have been
listen sorry this generation of vaccines
didn't work out let's do a deep dive we
probably would have found that there
were susceptible people we now know
that's the seniors who die with the
vaccine uh analyses from rose and
mclachlan have shown 50 of these deaths
occur within 48 hours 80 within a week
there's nursing homes studies from
europe and scandinavia that show when
they actually review the charts in the
seniors at least 40 percent the doctors
have concluded are directly due to the
vaccines the the these vignettes are
severe reactions fever chills nausea
vomiting uh blood pressure dropping and
then death within a day or two whether
it's basically a cardiopulmonary
collapse due to overwhelming production
of the spike protein or a thromboembolic
death or a bleeding death
a few weeks later but they are clearly
biologically related
to the vaccines now we're seeing
actually in obituaries there's an
obituary from washington state a young
woman where
in her obituary it states that she died
of vaccine-induced thrombocytopenic
propuria there's actually now new
vaccine deaths choi and colleagues
published a death of a myocarditis death
in a 22 year old korean young man who
took the vaccine
and uh you know these are young people
dying and now their obituaries and their
case reports are basically describing
the vaccine-induced fatal illness you
know our tolerance by the way for new
biologic or medicinal products and death
is about five cases gets a black box
warning 50 cases it's off the market
doesn't matter if it's
causally related or not it's off the
market and then a deep dive in terms of
safety what went wrong uh there's no
assumption of causality and on three
occasions now we've seen the cdc uh put
on their website that they've reviewed
the deaths and they just summarily
dismiss them as none of them being
caused by the vaccines and i can tell
you scientists in my circle don't don't
buy that at all
so what you're describing is an
apocalyptic failure of the
multiple layers of
fail-safe that are supposed to protect
us from such things
but
i know because i've been following this
story
that
this doesn't even begin
to get to the horror of it because not
only do we have a failure to remove this
product from the market even with a
safety signal that's orders of magnitude
bigger than it would need to be to alert
us to a problem under ordinary
circumstances
but we are turning civilization upside
down and playing with the idea of
mandates
to essentially bully anyone who wishes
to protect themself or them their family
from this product which as you're
describing it shouldn't be on the market
in the first place
anybody who wishes to protect themselves
from it is going to be stigmatized and
punished
is going to actually have civil
liberties removed in order to get them
to accept it
and so you know this is a failure that
has um it has breached the walls of
medicine and is now toppling
the most basic elements of our societal
agreement with each other and
i i must tell you it's setting off every
alarm bell um that i've got and i know
from inside of medicine um
that picture is even more stark because
you know for example most people
don't really know what myocarditis is
they don't know how to evaluate it when
they're told
yes there has been a certain amount of
myocarditis in young people but they
tend to to recover
so it's not such a serious concern what
do you as a doctor think when you hear a
claim like that
well let me just say that you know your
comments regarding i think death after
the vaccine uh being this charged issue
i i think americans and people across
the world would say listen covet 19 is a
bad illness i'm willing to put up with
almost anything to help everybody get
through it i'm willing to take a vaccine
to help everybody get through it but
people aren't willing to sacrifice their
lives for this
and that's what they're being asked for
they're being asked to say listen take a
vaccine and even though it's rare you
could lose your life and then people are
saying well how rare is rare
and i can just tell you the mortality
rate by all expert analyses is
unacceptably high we're at 18 000 people
in the
cdc u.s bears system about half of those
are domestic
americans
that have died with the vaccine
there is very good work done with the
cms data suggesting the under reporting
factor on this is about five
so if you take nine thousand times five
we currently are at
some number that is you know forty five
thousand fifty thousand and that's
conservative it could be greater than
that um that's under reporting by the
way via
projections from cms where we know
someone's died but you can imagine
that um the under reporting of people
who you know there's commotion at the
time of death i've seen this in my
circles and unless somebody retrieves
the vaccine cards and sits down at the
bare system and starts to make an entry
or unless somebody's on the rolls of cms
uh it may not actually be recorded
so we have it yeah we have a situation
where
there is this now cavalier type of um
situation with respect to death and you
ask the question who's making the
decision on the mandates do they care
whether or not there'll be some deaths
among their employee population do they
care if there's going to be some deaths
in the student population does anybody
really care and we're not seeing any
care or concern among those who are
making the decision on vaccine mandates
and i think that's what's uh frustrating
i mean you know we have we we have
mandates by the way for college kids to
take the meningococcal vaccine you've
never seen college protests or lawsuits
over the meningococcal vaccine i'm a
doctor we take hepatitis b vaccine and
flu vaccine every year you don't see us
outside protesting these vaccines but
you'll see massive protests people are
walking away from their jobs because
they know they could die with the
vaccine once the word get got out that
people could die after the van in fact
deaths were occurring in large numbers
that was by mid-april brett you know
rates in the vaccination in the united
states plummeted in mid-april they
absolutely plummeted uh the word got out
uh it doesn't matter what was on twitter
or on major media people were talking to
one another everyone knew and then we
saw a degree of really kind of gross
distorted
incentives you know the vaccines are
purely researched doctors cannot promote
them doctors can't um can't say the
doctors need to be completely neutral on
the vaccines as well as the hospitals
and anybody in a position of authority
because they're investigational if i
would have promoted the vaccines i would
have violated the nuremberg code which
is a principle of bioethics and i tell
you i'm a researcher but if i told my
patients listen you have to be in my
diabetes research study i and i forced
them into it through using my pressure
and coercive tactics or if my hospital
did that to my two patients and forced
them into research for diabetes for
instance uh you know we would be
sanctioned we'd be put up before all
kinds of ethics board and be sanctioned
so so good doctors never promoted the
vaccine they just could actually try to
provide fair balanced information that's
the only thing that good doctors good
health systems good health professionals
could do now we have the situation where
there's the non-fatal syndromes
myocarditis you mentioned them where the
fda agrees that the vaccines can cause
myocarditis they agreed in june based on
a universe of 600 cases 200 cases that
were reviewed it was clear was in
younger children uh it was serious 90
required hospitalization
and
in that
in fact they had uh syndromes chest pain
signs and symptoms of heart failures
markedly elevated cardiac troponins a
higher that we see in a heart attack far
greater than we ever see with minimal
troponin elevations with coveted
patients in the icu and
and these children required observations
some about a quarter in the fda review
already had some incipient heart failure
they had abnormal echocardiograms i
infer left ventricular dysfunction they
needed actually drugs to try to prevent
the development of heart failure or
active treatment of heart failure we had
in the new england journal medicine this
summer we had a fatal case reported now
we've had a fatal case from korea and
then to go fast forward from 200 cases
at the fda and cdc agreed on in june to
11 000 cases in vares and i can tell you
these are the ones that are certified
i've actually reported myocarditis cases
as a doctor in varus and you get called
by the cdc and the cdc officer you go
down you go over all the reports you go
over all the lab reports uh and and
there's an agreement that in fact the
vaccine caused myocarditis tracy hoag
reported from uc davis now thousands of
cases using varus and vsaf ages 12 to 17
explosive myocarditis after the second
shot of messenger rna vaccine boys way
more than girls and in fact tracy's
estimates are that the um the real rate
of myocarditis is at least 50 percent
greater than what the cdc ever projected
she still found 86 required
hospitalization and the most shocking
thing of the hog analysis was that a
child age age 12 to 17
is more likely to be hospitalized with
myocarditis than taking your chances
with covid and ever getting hospitalized
with covid and the hog analysis as well
as a parallel analysis by ron costaff
looking at death which is even more
important death after the vaccine at any
age group is more likely than actually
taking your chances with covet 19 and
dying of covert and the reason why
that's important is what's called
determinism when one takes the vaccine
it's a 100 chance they're exposed to the
to the fatal uh exposure or the
injurious exposure if one takes their
chances with covet 19 it's not a hundred
percent they're going to get the illness
matter of fact many patients dodge
copit19 many are already have already
had it so they're naturally immune they
connect they can't be injured again with
getting the respiratory illness so you
can see how this wager is levered both
of those analyses were presented by
external reviewers to the fda at the
meetings the adolescent and childhood
meetings in september and october and
they weren't disputed
so this is this is really extraordinary
these analyses now no one is just
speaking these analyses it's a better
proposition to defer on the vaccine and
then manage covet if it comes up it's a
better proposition if you do it blind
you have described the importance of
stratifying by age but there's also
stratifying by other risk factors and if
you're looking at a healthy child
the point is they have almost no risk
uh that's not that they can't contract
covet but the likelihood that it's going
to hobble them in any permanent way is
effectively zero so we can stratify this
such that we can just take a large group
of people people to whom we owe our
our deepest commitment to protect them
and just simply eliminate them from the
experiment and yet we are not doing it
which i find
i'm looking for a synonym for ghastly
and i can't quite find one
but
let me ask you this i know a bit about
things like heart damage from work i did
many years ago on
the dynamics of
telomeres and various tissues in the
body
when someone tells me
that
young people
have had uh serious damage to the heart
but that they recover from it my first
thought is
they may recover from it in the short
term but it is not that they have not
been robbed of longevity
is that a fair statement as a doctor
does it strike you that
patients young patients who have had
myocarditis but leave the hospital are
going to
have uh if we were to treat them as a
group statistically are they going to
have normal lifespans or are they likely
to be vulnerable
to other phenomena as they get older
well let's look at this i've recently
been asked to lecture on myocarditis i'm
a cardiologist i practice both internal
medicine and adult cardiology and so um
i want to quote a paper by arola and
colleagues from finland now this is uh
several years ago before covid but it's
in this uh childhood group that you
mentioned all the way up through
adolescence and the rate of in finland
had everybody uh they had everybody who
does myocarditis the background rate is
four cases per 1 million per year
and in the united states we roughly have
half of the population before below age
50. so we have 160 million people
below age 50 in the united states in the
analysis from theirs by rose and myself
and i know you featured this on a prior
broadcast that we showed that the
myocarditis by the way after the
vaccines
is a skewed distribution but the tail
goes all the way up to age 50. so this
applies so in the united states our
background case is four cases
per million and we have a hundred and
sixty so it's four times 160 we should
basically have 640 cases of myocarditis
per year
that is a background rate i've told you
so far our var system has 11 000 cases
11 000 so we are far beyond the
background rate
what we know is in an analysis by
avoglio so very similar last name that
the spike protein itself is the
injurious um element of the vaccine
and the cell type that actually looks
like it's the cell involved democratized
is called the pericyte which is around
capillaries in the heart and the
cardiomyocytes
and then your question is wait a minute
if the kids take some heart damage and
even if it's transitory
is there a long-term risk
in a paper by uh to shopee and
colleagues in circulation research in
2019 looking at myocarditis before covid
but this myocarditis in general that
comes through
parvo virus it comes through various
forms of adenoviruses
etc the rate of permanent damage and
things going poorly over time in this
group of people is about 13
and that number
brett is high i can tell you 13 if that
holds for vaccine-induced myocarditis
and i anticipate it will
i think that is an extraordinary number
of young individuals
that is going to have permanent heart
damage we're talking about the
development of heart failure
the need for heart failure medications
risks for
cardiac death and things we have to do
about that including implantable
defibrillators
some some children going all the way to
heart transplantation
there shouldn't be a single case of
excess case of myocarditis out there not
a not one case is acceptable let alone
be sitting on 11 000 and now with school
vaccine mandates for children you can
see that number is going to skyrocket 11
000 which is again a verse number which
every analysis that has been done tells
us that verse is dramatically under
reported it's a very conservative system
so
um
this is an extraordinary
harm
that is being done am i right so far
well you you this we haven't talked
about this but um i was on national tv
in june when the fda and cdc reviewed
myocarditis and they said two things
that i think was completely incorrect
from a public health perspective and you
know i'm trained in public health i'm a
uh i'm a uh at this point time my career
i've over 650 publications in the
national library of medicine and pubmed
i'm the i'm an editor of a major
cardiology journal former editor of
another journal you know i'm the
principal editor of my own textbook i am
in academic medicine right now and
anybody you're talking to covet 19 i
imagine i'm probably
at the top of the academic pile right
now of a scholarship i can tell you
those two statements by our public
health officials who are junior to me in
their scholarship and accomplishments
both of those statements i think are
reprehensible they said and reckless
they said that myocarditis is mild and
they said it was rare well it wasn't
mild then because 90 of the kids are in
the hospital by regulatory standards
anything that causes hospitalization as
you know is a serious adverse event it's
never classified as mild never and then
they said it was rare because they took
200 cases and they divided by the
universe and people got the vaccine well
we can't do that in safety because we
didn't assess everybody from myocarditis
so we don't know if it's rare and when
we see a signal like this in safety
pharmacovigilance we use the term tip of
the iceberg so i was on national tv
saying listen it's not mild because the
kids are being hospitalized and two it's
not rare it's the tip of the iceberg and
boy was i right being at now 11 000
cases in bears and you're right it's
under reported
and interestingly it's who reports it
the um there is a paper
that's published in the american college
of pediatrics that asked the question in
2016 who reports to theirs and you know
who reports to bears the answer was
about
about 14 percent of the time
it's
it's actually the patient or the
patient's family that reports to theirs
86 of the time it's another entity that
actually really was concerned that the
the product uh in this case the vaccine
caused the problems that means doctors
nurses people administered the vaccine
the pharmaceutical companies who receive
this and they're concerned about their
products so i have to tell you this
vares data
uh is real
uh and i've heard people say that oh
anybody can report things to theirs i
filled out the various sheets brett and
i'll tell you every single page says
warning um this is uh falsification is
punishable by imprisonment or federal
fines i tell you right now the vare
system 11 000 cases that's serious
and the number almost certainly is going
to be much larger if this under
reporting relationship exists in fact
that number of five on mortality it may
be greater for myocarditis because if
you look at the registrational trials
and children the one by frank and
colleagues for instance in the
adolescence
40 percent of the kids who get the
vaccines develop fever as high as 40
degrees they have muscle aches body
aches they feel very sick after shot
number one and shot number two that
constitutional syndrome could actually
mask some chest pain that would be
missed myocarditis so as i am as a
clinician who's seeing this i can tell
you right now i am suspicious the rates
of myocarditis are going to be
astronomical
all right so you have just described uh
a catastrophic picture that is itself
the tip of a different iceberg because
what people really need to think
carefully about
is
we are
mandating or we are considering
mandating for children who have
essentially no risk from kovid but
that's not even the full extent of it a
child who gets coveted
has
very little harm that comes to them as
far as we know a healthy child
walks away
with
what if a vaccine could accomplish it
would be considered miraculous which is
essentially perfect immunity to the
disease going forward
and we would be vaccinating them to
prevent them from catching the disease
that would prevent them from developing
this robust broad immunity to covid
until later when it does become a threat
when they're older and the disease is
more dangerous to them right
and we would be doing this and when you
really push people and you say why are
we vaccinating children for a disease
that does not threaten them the best
answer that comes back
is terrible the answer is that
effectively
this is to control
the pandemic now
we can argue all day about whether or
not this actually does control the
pandemic better than children
contracting covid having very low
symptoms and walking away with permanent
immunity but what we can't argue is that
that rationale
effectively borrows health from young
people to protect the old and infirm and
so you mentioned the nuremberg code
before
and unfortunately i think we really need
to think about what's going on in those
terms
no healthy society takes health from
young people in order to protect the old
and infirm that is not an acceptable
ethical trade
and yet we are doing it without
discussion which suggests that something
that effectively the bottom has dropped
out of the bucket that
the commitments that we have to each
other
the idea of medical ethics has all been
subordinated to a reckless top-down
campaign focused on a single remedy that
we now know
as amazing as it is at a technological
level
is composed of
unfortunate features and full of design
failures you mentioned the spike protein
that was a very poor choice of a protein
to alert the immune system to the
chemical nature of covid because the
spike protein is itself dangerous right
now i've gotten in trouble i've been
quote unquote fact checked for that
being said on darkhorse but of course
this is what you're telling us that the
spike protein is actually doing damage
to the body sometimes that damages to
the heart a tissue that has a very low
capacity for self-repair
and that we would do this to children
for no benefit to them
is simply unconscionable
you know i've been fact checked by uh by
fact checkers they actually stopped you
know why brett because i quote the
literature i cite the literature and i
ask the fact checkers to go ahead and
review that paper and make that paper
even more prominent
on the internet and they then they
obviously they they dropped me like a a
like a hot potato because they know i'm
i'm dead on with respect to the citation
so i hope they actually pull a volio
they pull the finished paper in fact
they should they should be able to do
this and we'll be laser focused let me
just say a couple things you mentioned
this term of
radical fx nuremberg code says
under no conditions should anyone
receive any pressure coercion or threat
of reprisal for having something
injected into their body as we apply it
to vaccines in the setting of research
and that's what actually happened in
nazi germany with the nazi research
program
and then the second one is the
declaration of helsinki there's six of
these cornerstones of bioethics that our
office of human research protections in
washington actually holds the second one
is the declaration of helsinki that
indicates that everyone should receive
informed consent and uh recently i was
on the diane andrews show in baton rouge
louisiana and she reminded me of the
tuskegee program in macon county georgia
in alabama i'm sorry and what was done
there is roughly 600 african-american
men were recruited into a study of
syphilis and they were told that the
study was going to prevent syphilis they
weren't told whether or not they had it
at baseline they were given effectively
placebos and this program brett went
from 1932 to 1972.
it turns out in the mid 1940s penicillin
became available
they the investigators of the program
didn't make penicillin available to
those who had syphilis they let the men
give it to their wives and then give it
to their children
and this program brett who was it run by
it was run by the cdc it was run by the
public health service in the cdc do you
know that there were senate hearings
there never were any apologies that some
people stepped down it ultimately in 19
early 1990s former president clinton had
to step up and formally apologize now to
the spouses and the progeny of those in
the tuskegee
experiment
and say we're sorry for this and give
reparations the cdc and the fda is
running the u.s
covet 19 vaccine program i'm not seeing
anybody interested in saying they're
sorry
i think this is going to be taken this
is just like tuskegee over and over
again i think this is very similar to
the nazi
doctor
crimes and all the same techniques are
being used propaganda false information
given by those in position of authority
and then malfeasance which is actually
wrongdoing by those in position of
authority you get signs and symptoms of
this you know there's been a couple fda
officials they just can't stomach
anymore and they've resigned in fact dr
gruber who actually signed the
biological licensing agreement to for
cameronnetti bioentec uh she resigned
seven days after she signed that
biological licensing agreement uh letter
as an example one of her colleagues did
as well francis collins uh the head of
the national
institute of health he's retiring i'm
telling you right now this is the
medical super bowl for the nih the fda
and the cdc there should be zero
resignations these people ought to be
absolutely triumphant in their victory
of a public health program and yet
they're heading for the exits this
really ought to tell you something about
where we are going right now you're
right the bioethical principles are off
the wall historians will record do you
know the world health organization
recently said by ascent a child
showing up to school by ascent is
actually agreeing to the covet 19
vaccination
uh
my child certainly isn't i'll tell you
that much um
yes
you know i've been wrestling with
um
with the nazi
parallel and the tuskegee parallel
myself and i feel
i think like many people do an absolute
obligation not to invoke those things
unless
it is absolutely warranted but the
problem is
it's not a perfect parallel but it's
certainly the closest thing that we've
got
right the vaccination
of
children
under false pretenses is very
tuskegee-like and this time race is not
the
uh
the issue but
nonetheless
i i don't see how there is any ambiguity
on this point at all and what i don't
understand is
um i don't think you need to be all that
informed or all that smart to see the
problem with vaccinating children who
are not threatened by this disease right
it's not that complex and once you find
out that that's what we intend to do
it should open your eyes to all of the
other things that are wrong with what we
are doing so for example
the vaccine program
is riding on the claim that we don't
have alternatives
now at the beginning of covid we really
didn't know what to do but that's no
longer the case we have learned a
tremendous amount about how to treat it
and how not to treat it and so let's say
that the vaccines were off the table and
you had
let's say that the environment was
hospitable to using every tool at your
disposal
how empowered do you feel as a doctor to
treat a vulnerable patient who shows up
with a positive test but uh is not yet
very sick
every doctor should feel fully
enabled to treat this illness just like
a pneumococcal pneumonia just like
influenza pneumonia come on we do this
as internists as family doctors as
medical specialists and i've done it
from the very beginning i testified
under oath i have never denied a high
risk patient early treatment for covert
19 using my best medical judgment
because we knew the chinese were telling
us right out of the gate that this could
be fatal in some individuals i can tell
you as a doctor i took an oath
i took an oath to do the best i can i
would never let someone acquire a fatal
illness
and do nothing
i just never would do that that's called
failure to treat that's called
malpractice
and um so i want to stop you there
because i think people will not
necessarily know what you're talking
about what you're talking about is that
actually the quote-unquote standard of
care involves
essentially sending you home if you're
not sick enough to require medical help
we do not treat those who have just
tested positive
because
it is not acknowledged that we have
useful tools is that fair
it's uh it's a situation where we know
that the illness
takes two to four weeks to become fatal
we know this now and we may not have
known it in february of of 2020 but we
know it now
and so we also know with every infection
when we start early we have the best
chances of quelling the infection before
it becomes feminine and ultimately fatal
do you know for bacterial
infections we actually have tricks from
the time the patient presents to the
time the first antimicrobial is
administered that's actually a quality
metric the same thing should exist for
covet 19. now the interesting thing
about covet 19 is not everybody needs
treatment we have estimates that roughly
25
of the population needs treatment from
covet 19 we know that from an iranian
study by mocterry and colleagues over 30
000 individuals with covet 19 we've
looked at the iranian program which is a
hydroxychloroquine-based program it's
enormously successful
they can give relatively brief courses
of hydroxychloroquine plus other drugs
in combination
to individuals who are at high risk now
risk stratification is so sophisticated
but by this point in time any listener
can go to the cleveland clinic website
type in their age their medical problems
and they can actually calculate their
risk of hospitalization and death with
covet 19 at the time the testing
positive this is so easily risk
stratifiable and so i've always said in
the first paper i published on this the
american journal medicine in 2020
and then the follow-up in reviews in
cardiovascular medicine december of 2020
these are the most frequently downloaded
and utilized papers in all of the
treatment of covet 19 they were the
basis for the very first treatment
protocol to americans and to people
worldwide that was supported by a
physician organization that's chartered
in every state in the united states the
association of american physician and
surgeons now we've been ahead of this
we've been ahead of every other group on
this using what's called sequence
multi-drug therapy provided to americans
either through their doctors through
referring doctors or through
telemedicine services so getting back to
the issue of a patient in front of me
who's sick with covet 19 the first step
is risk stratification if i have
somebody who's clearly over age 50 with
medical problems the risk of
hospitalization and death rises to
greater than one percent that's a
threshold to start doing something
we take somebody let's say over 65 with
heart disease lung disease diabetes
obesity that's common
we could end up with risks of 20 to 40
percent for hospitalization that's
clearly enough to do something on day
one as opposed to day 14. so i testified
actually in the u.s senate in november
and i did comment about what you said
the very first set of nih guidelines
that came out and the nih is not a
guidelines organization i want your
listeners to know this they are not in
the guidelines business they are not in
the business of giving treatment
recommendations but they tried and prior
to that the infectious disease inside of
america had three or four versions of
guidelines
both the nih and the idsa focused on
inpatients it was clear their focus was
in patients they had no approach for
outpatients what the nih said i thought
was particularly uh
impressive and historians were right
about this they specifically said if a
high-risk patient gets covered 19 they
go home they do nothing
they literally wait until they can't
take it anymore and they can't breathe
anymore they go to the hospital and you
still do nothing still do nothing until
the point of requiring oxygenation and
at that point in time then the first
milligram of rem deserver can be given i
can tell you that is is the type of
situation i can tell you as a senior
doctor who's treated many patients with
covered 19
that i would take that guideline and
tell them listen that is going to cause
harm to the population it is a harmful
document we'd be better off without it
we'd be better off with out without
other sources of guidance and just go
with aaps use risk stratification and
start treating patients and prevent the
hospitalization and prevent death i've
always said this there's only two bad
outcomes hospitalization and death it's
clear i think if people knew they could
get covered 19 but make it through at
home uh that home treatment would always
win because of these principles we
shortened the infectivity period from 14
days down to four days fourteen to four
days and that we reduce the intensity
and duration of symptoms the drugs
aren't perfect but we need four to six
drugs in combination single drugs don't
work by the way we need four to six
drugs in combination just like with hiv
just like with the hepatitis the other
viral infections
and that by that mechanism
we allow the virus to terminate in the
house and not let it spread elsewhere if
we let it brew in the house for two
weeks and then there's a panic to the
clinic or the hospital we infect other
care workers family members et cetera so
every hospitalization in the united
states has actually been a super
spreader event recently aaron rodgers
was criticized because he got coveted
19. well i mentioned and i'm going to
mention i'm going to go on joe rogan
shortly and basically recap this that
aaron rodgers did the right thing he did
the exact same thing i did i had cover
19. what did i do i got it home i got
involved in a multi-drug treatment
protocol i and i was in research so i
was doing swabs every day aaron probably
wasn't but i shortened my infectivity
down to four days i proved that i did
all my contact tracing so did my wife we
didn't spread it to anyone and we were
done and then on the back side of this
now we're naturally immune now aaron
rodgers can return to the packers and he
can never get covered 19 again and he
can never spread it again that's very
different than taking a vaccine if he
would have taken a vaccine he clearly
could have gotten it anyway and somebody
who's vaccinated clearly can spread it
to others and our cdc director then all
the data suggests that in fact that's
the case okay so
the central thing for me i've been
trying to understand what i'm seeing and
this terrible public health response to
an admittedly bad but
manageable disease
and i can't escape the following thought
and you almost stated it right there you
said we would have been better off
without the guidelines
my sense is
that you could have
a good proper response
you could have an incompetent response
or you could have something else and the
problem is that so much of what i see
when i dig a little bit into the
evidence i find that our response is not
only incompetent but it is very often
the inverse of what would be the
responsible thing to do so for example
not treating people until very late in
the progress of covet disease that is
the way to ensure that what treatment
you offer is least effective right
it's a terrible recommendation it's the
inverse of the the right thing the idea
that vaccines are the way to control
this disease again
these vaccines are not capable they are
at best feeble the effectiveness wanes
very rapidly over time they cause
disease in their own right these are not
the right tools we have other tools and
we are not recommending their use you
mentioned
uh various drugs that work do you want
to
name a few that you think are useful
here
let me just comment on your your
interpretation of public health
responses um scott atlas's book is out
and he's been on tv i've personally you
know had dinner with him we went over it
you know he was on the inside he
actually met with the public health
officials he was at these meetings and i
was shocked with what i heard he said
that our public health officials the
ones we see on tv throughout the course
of the pandemic they showed up to
meetings with no scientific data they
had not reviewed manuscripts they were
not prepared scott said he was the only
person showing up with new studies
interpreting what was going on
i was flabbergasted i said scott is it
is it true that it's actually
incompetence that america is suffering
basically gross incompetence by our
public health officials and he said yes
he thinks that it's actually gross
incompetence well i have to say i think
you're both wrong
i think this can't be explained by
incompetence incompetence would give you
something like a
random set of recommendations right
perfect incompetence would give you a
random set instead what we have is
closer to the inverse of the right
recommendations right the failure to
recommend vitamin d supplementation
is glaring the amount of covert that
could be prevented and controlled with
vitamin d is large the safety of vitamin
d is clear
and even if it didn't work even if we
were incorrect about this the collateral
benefits for supplementing vitamin d
especially during the winter are clear
enough on their own so we're not doing
that
um we now have randomized controlled
trials which we are told bizarrely are
the only kind of evidence that is
acceptable we have evidence that
flavoxamine is uh effective against
covid and yet
i see no evidence of a rapid move to add
that to the standard of care it's almost
as if
something has focused on a single
solution for reasons that aren't medical
or epidemiological
and it is going to rewrite
whatever evidence it runs into it's
going to dismiss and rationalize away
every alternative to that one
uh prescribed remedy and so you know i
don't i don't mean to contradict you i
just think you're being
uh more cautious than the evidence
warrants here we are we are looking at
something beyond incompetence well you
know i was giving uh and to be fair to
scott atlas um i was basically giving
you his interpretation i was at a
symposium in columbus and somebody asked
him that very question
they said you know is it really
incompetence or is it the inverse is it
something really worse than that and his
answer was he does think that those in
positions of power in the public health
do want the crisis to end and they are
doing in a sense they do have good
intentions and he did say that
specifically i was in the audience i
listened and i imagine his book says the
same thing but he's very clear about the
instances of incompetence and simply not
following the data but when you get to
the inverse but you're really getting to
brett you're getting very close to a an
adjective which is nefarious meaning are
people actually intentionally trying to
do harm and the book to point to there i
wrote one of the introductions is covet
19 and the global predators we are the
prey by peter bregen and i have to tell
you it i think it's number one in a lot
of the uh medical book listings right
now it has a thousand citations of
evidence this is a factual book of it's
basically non-fiction
and it's laying out
what almost certainly is according to
bregan nefarious intent there is intent
to make things worse
and you know i gave my interpretation to
tucker carlson earlier this year i was
on i said tucker listen i'm just a
doctor seeing this
but i think there is intentional
suppression of early treatment i think
there is intentional
uh promotion of masking lockdowns
isolation fear suffering hospitalization
and death in order to
mass promote the vaccine that was my
interpretation now many months ago and i
gave americans that interpretation on tv
so i am aligned with you
is more than just innocent incompetence
well
that that there is an agenda there is
absolutely no doubt about it there is a
vaccine agenda that is being carried out
so i want to introduce uh i don't know
what's going on and i'm agnostic about
the intent behind it but i think there
is a kind of
middle ground explanation that fits the
agnosticism and that is
we have the something like the inverse
of the policy that you would recommend
if you were really trying to help
patients and and the pandemic
that can't be explained by incompetence
it could be explained
by
a
public health response built around a
remedy that does not
update
in other words if you got really excited
about these vaccines before you knew how
feeble they were and how many design
flaws they have within them
and you just never checked in with
whether or not these were still the best
treatment you could end up
disrupting
the recognition of alternative tools
that work as a result of
you know
absolutely unacceptable indefensible
commitment to a single remedy that
frankly is making a uh
you know as part of a
profit-making endeavor
so you could do that without the intent
to make things worse now i'm not saying
there is no intent to make things worse
and i think you point to something else
that we need to be thinking about which
is
covid
the disease and the pandemic
is a real phenomenon and then there is a
question of the political apparatus and
what use it's putting it to and so the
idea that you know
masking is everywhere despite uh
quite ambiguous evidence about how
effective it is
um that lockdowns are also uh likely not
appropriate in this case not effective
that if you were going to use quarantine
you could you could use a different
strategy that that might be the
political apparatus riding on the
reality of covid and doing something yes
i would argue quite nefarious but that
it is not medically nefarious it is
politically nefarious and masquerading
as a medical policy
um and i you know again i'm not telling
you that i think i know what's taking
place here i'm just telling you i think
we need to parse very carefully that um
we do have evidence this isn't
incompetence
that may mean it's nefarious it could be
partially nefarious it could be uh
somewhere in between but that at the
very least people need to be
aware
that
the thing that is telling them what is
in their interests and what is in our
collective interest is misleading them
and that can very clearly be seen in
failure to recommend vitamin d
to a population that is almost certainly
deficient it can be seen in the
recommendation of vaccination for
children for whom it does not provide a
medical benefit and uh
pretty clearly provides the opposite um
it can be seen in the
policy of sending people home until
they're so sick
and have been delayed so long that they
can't be effectively treated all of
these things are strong indicators that
whatever authoritative voice that is
it has been
captured or destroyed and that we must
listen to people like you who have
experience on the ground and say look
this is how you treat covid this is what
we see in patients and uh you know
you can't listen to those authorities
because that's not what they are
well it should be unsurprising
that
you know academic physicians who have
experience treating covet 19
have robust publication track records in
covid19 it should be unsurprising that
they would have a superior position
in terms of recommendations than a
public health official it's just what it
is i mean public health officials
are not treating patients with covet 19
they are not
really on the vanguard of cutting-edge
science i mean i am like many you've
interviewed i am in
innumerable symposiums and involved in
inter information interchange all over
the world
right now and our public health
officials aren't americans know that
because we've seen no window to the
outside world
and to speak to your interpretation of
political intent you know there must be
some political intent with the public
health response because it's so
different in every country so if it was
all about the medical problem we would
settle on some uniform standards but you
know in sweden where things have been
wide open to begin with and you go i
just got a message from cyprus the
island of cyprus now where they are
completely in total lockdown masking
24x7 inside outside with severe
penalties one must get a text message
approval to leave one's house in cyprus
wow and they have hardly any covid i was
on chris saucedo a news show a week or
two ago and there was a report that in
taiwan there's more vaccine deaths than
there are coveted deaths the same thing
is true in australia so you know that
somehow the agenda involves vaccines
to the complete and total end the
vaccines will cause more deaths than
covet and the vaccines will be carried
out to the complete end here where the
vaccines in the end will become more of
a problem than coven you can already see
that in low prevalence countries you can
also see a very interesting trend
emerging in the least vaccinated parts
of the world there's the least threat of
covid including
uh central africa for instance uh for
the vaccination rates are six percent
and they're basically breezing through
covid whereas you get to places like
gibraltar the uk
um iceland uh now uh uh uh
you know now america and canada are
emerging wherever we are vaccinating
more intensely we have a much greater
problem with covet till to this day i'm
shocked as an american where one-sixth
of the u.s population we still have more
cases and more coven-19 deaths than any
country in the world and we have the top
medical system in the united states
uniquely you know we have 5600 hospitals
20 200 acute care centers 300 medical
schools do you know that not a single
major medical institution has their own
unique research protocol we are two
years into this and it's shocking that
there's no harvard treatment protocol
for covid19 there's no mayo clinic
treatment call or duke treatment they
have their own individual protocols
which they actually uh showcase for
their research and innovation for every
medical problem under the sun suddenly
in covet 19 our academic
uh intelligence
is zero on cover 19. i think it's
shocking i think it's absolutely as
people like me and merrick and just a
few independent leaders broke through to
the world on how to treat covet 19 and
our major medical schools have fallen
flat right so the normal process in
which there would be protocols coming
out of the top medical schools is
nowhere in evidence and somehow
bizarrely even though it is widely
understood that we have a regulatory
capture problem involving pharma
the assumption of most people seems to
be that there's not even an average
level of pharma corruption with respect
to covid but that the level of
corruption is actually zero i don't
understand
why anyone would assume that what they
were seeing is a pure public health
response rather than at least leaving
open the possibility that some of the
nonsense that we're seeing and some of
the paradoxes that we're being uh told
to accept uh are the result of of
corruption that we know exists on any
other you know in any other year
and
well just to answer that you know it may
be systemic and so i think a lot of the
rooting of this is going to be looking
at the federal payments that have come
into medical centers that have come into
medical practices from the federal
government through a variety of programs
in a sense covered relief funding
that could be auditable with respect to
the faqs and potentially the
instructions of use for the funds which
involve you know supportment support of
the federal efforts support of the
vaccine program support of the narrative
if you will on treatment of covid19 so
it may be that the medical schools
actually would want to try an innovative
protocol but they felt that the federal
funding may be threatened if they did so
that they in fact they should just stay
on track with use of nih guidelines
drugs like rem deserver and
dexamethasone
and they felt that somehow it may
actually all tie back to the the federal
funding i listen there are so many
bright people at these institutions i
can't imagine
that there wouldn't be a doctor who
would want to try anti-androgens or try
fluvoxamine or wouldn't try to there are
so many young people who want to get
grants and they want to get notoriety
how could there be no interest in
getting notoriety in treating the
biggest public health problem
of our time the biggest public health
problem of our time where almost all of
medicine is self-sabotaging and so it
would be easy to stand out
but the social pressure and the
political pressure not to
uh i believe is explanatory you
expressed some
hopefulness that ultimately historians
will sort this out i must tell you i
have a fear
that uh
the crime here is substantial enough
that
there will be a huge investment in
preventing historians from ever figuring
out what happened i hope the historians
are up to the challenge
i know you you have to go i want to be
very respectful of your time i do have
one last thing i'm going to ask you
about
your paper with jessica rose
revealed another oddity
of um of the coveted pandemic in our
academic scientific and medical response
to it can you say what happened with
that paper and how unusual it is in your
experience
the paper is a descriptive analysis
using the vares system and just the
domestic us cases
jessica rose who's a top-notch viral
epidemiologist and myself so i'm a
cardiologist so we had the two skill
sets to analyze the data and it's just
describing the cases of errors largely
the age and gender distributions it's
non-controversial
it's not comparative in any way
and uh jessica uh
made the
author decision to submit it to current
problems in cardiology
in that journal when a paper is
submitted there there is in a sense an
editorial dialogue of whether or not the
paper is of interest to the editor and
she has that dialogue showing it's of
interest it's kind of a welcomed paper
to the journal
and then it goes through the peer review
process and it went through the peer
review process
was
accepted
and through that you know there were
publication fees paid a publication
contract copyright color figure fees
paid i know because i paid them brett so
i told jessica i take care of the
finances on the paper um all of this is
signed and sealed contracted
then it's cited in the national library
of medicine so that's a done deal the
paper is part of medical history it's in
the record books now
and then um when it's out there for
several weeks and heavily utilized uh as
we approach the first meeting the
pediatric meeting on vaccination age
five to eleven that's where this paper
would really be jermaine for those
researching the meeting
we were shocked to learn that uh without
any notification of us that the
publisher elsevier had taken it down out
of pubmed the citation is still there
but they've taken it down it says
temporarily withdrawn then we got a
notice from elsevier saying that where
they're withdrawing it because uh they
looked uh they believed that they didn't
invite the paper to begin with
so i reviewed the contract i said can
they really do that it was obvious the
paper was welcomed invited we got the
editorial dog if if they didn't want the
paper breath they would have said we're
not interested it's not invited don't
don't you know they would have told us
to go somewhere else they obviously
didn't do that and they wouldn't they
wouldn't have sent it to peers it's a
posterous explanation it wouldn't go
through but i did look over the the um
contractual aspects of this and they
could have withdrawn it if if they found
scientific invalidity if they found
something that that um later on they do
have the right you know every so often
the science is wrong uh you remember the
lancet paper on hydroxyquarquin which is
a fraudulent paper and it was found out
afterwards and it was taken down they
could have done this if they said oh it
was a fraudulent paper or that they you
know we didn't have the right data what
have you that wasn't the excuse so um of
interest we we asked el severe we said
listen are you sure you want to do this
um because uh you know it's obvious
there's a um there's a lot of
ramifications there elsevier is the
biggest publisher in the world they said
yeah we're sure we want to do this and
we said okay so we're in the process of
filing a lawsuit against elsevier it's
going to be very costly to el severe
elsevier which proudly touts itself as
the intellectual descendant of galileo's
publisher which i find fascinating in
this case
well elsa elsevier is going to be
absolutely slaughtered on this and i can
make that a promise um and because it's
not only breach of contract
but it's tortuous interference with the
business of academic medicine where our
business is to disseminate scientific
information so this is going to be taken
to the highest levels we'll have us and
litigators in the netherlands this will
draw more attention to the paper
than
where whatever the stakeholders were
there obviously were stakeholders that
did not want this information to get to
the public before the fda pediatric
meeting and through the discovery of
this brett we will find out who the
stakeholders are well i'm looking
forward to finding out with you um
let me ask you this you said you have
600 plus publications to your name
yeah i i'm i have if you search me in
pubmed i think i'm at about 660
peer-reviewed publications
in pubmed and there's a sizable fraction
where i'm either the first author or the
senior author
so i can tell your listeners right now
um i'm in the upper echelon of all
published physicians in the world right
now at my age
and i publish broadly in medicine and i
know what i'm talking about i'm an
editor myself and how often have you
seen something like this this does not
happen
this is effectively it is academic
malfeasance it's wrongdoing by elsevier
right now and they are basically caught
red-handed in what is censorship on a
very important topic to the world right
now
all right well i'm going to let you go
it's been an absolute pleasure
please
continue to fight the good fight on all
of our behalf and uh i i look forward to
our next opportunity to chat
thanks so much for your interview all
right be well
you